vamos a hacer un tercer ejemplo de
graficar una función racional y es que
esto realmente no se puede practicar
demás bueno la que vamos a hacer es
igual a x dividido entre x al cuadrado
menos x menos 6 y lo primero que voy a
hacer es factorizar el denominador para
ver cuando esta expresión está
indefinida y para encontrar las asientos
verticales vale bueno abajo tenemos una
expresión cuadrática entonces tenemos
que encontrar dos números que
multiplicados nos den menos 6 y que
sumados nos den menos uno creo que tres
y dos con algunos signos adecuados
funcionan sí creo que x + 2 con x menos
3 funciona a haber 2 x menos 13 es menos
6 2 menos 13 es menos 1 muy bien
entonces podemos reescribir esta
expresión racional como x / / / x + 2 x
x 3 entonces ya tenemos los puntos en
los cuales el denominador se hace igual
a 0 verdad es cuando x + 2 es igual a 0
o bien cuando x menos 3 es igual a 0
cuando x es igual a menos 2 lo voy a
poner por aquí cuando x es igual a menos
2 o cuando x es igual a 3 va entonces
ahí se anula el denominador pero para
tener asiento está vertical
necesitamos que además esos términos no
se cancelen con nada del numerador y en
efecto no se cancela con nada verdad
arriba no hay ni x2 ni x 3
entonces x igual a menos 2 y es igual a
3 si son las síntomas déjame ponerlas
aquí en el dibujo entonces x igual a
menos 12 es por acá voy a poner así las
líneas punteadas como siempre aquí
tenemos una sin tota vertical en x igual
a menos 2 y tenemos otra a sin tota
vertical en x igual a 3 entonces viene
por acá y sube y sube y sube y baja la
línea punteada ok entonces ahí tenemos
otra sin tota vertical vale bueno ahora
qué sucede con las cintas horizontales
tendremos alguna sin tota horizontal
bueno pues qué sucede cuando x se hace
muy muy grande
tenemos que analizar los términos de
mayor grado en el numerador y en el
denominador en el numerador tenemos
grado 1 y en el denominador tenemos
grado 2
aquí tenemos x y aquí x al cuadrado
entonces resulta que el x al cuadrado le
gana a todo lo demás a qué me refiero
con esto pues imagínate que ponemos un
1.000.000 si ponemos un millón aquí
arriba nos queda un millón aquí abajo un
millón al cuadrado y aquí otras cosas
que son pequeñas en comparación con el
un millón al cuadrado entonces nos
quedaría como un millón entre un millón
al cuadrado y eso es como uno entre un
millón o sea realmente este x al
cuadrado hace que lo que pongamos abajo
importe mucho más de modo que si ponemos
una equis muy muy muy muy grande pues
entonces vamos a dividir entre algo muy
muy grande y nos vamos a ir a cero
entonces conforme x conforme x tiende a
infinito
tenemos que tiende a cero y lo mismo si
x tiende a menos infinito vale de esta
forma vamos a tener una cinta un asiento
está horizontal en de igual a cero
con este color azul está básicamente
sobre el eje x entonces ahí tenemos la
línea igual a 0 que es el eje x vale
entonces otra vez como le hicimos pues
comparamos términos de mayor grado
arriba el grado es 1 abajo el grado es 2
el denominador tiene mayor grado
entonces esta expresión se va a ir a 0
de hecho hasta lo podemos verificar con
la calculadora si vamos a hacer eso nada
más para para que veamos cómo salen las
cuentas vamos a probar valores 10 100 y
1000 entonces voy a sacar la calculó que
ham encenderla voy a salirme de esta
gráfica entonces vamos a ver qué pasa si
le ponemos digamos x igual a 10 entonces
tenemos que hacer 10 sin eso no es cero
10 10 dividido entre aquí voy a abrir
paréntesis para poner el denominador 10
al cuadrado menos 10 menos 10 menos 6
menos 6 bueno x igual a 10 no es tan
grande así que no es tan cercano a cero
pero ya es menos de uno es punto uno
vale estoy es chiquito vamos a ver qué
pasa si ponemos una equis más
grande déjame copiar la entrada anterior
y aquí voy a poner ahora x igual a 100
entonces necesito meter un 0 aquí es un
cero a esta otro 6 tercero ahora vamos a
meter otra vez el cero y por acá también
entonces un cero más
le damos enter y mira nos vamos
acercando cada vez más a cero tenemos
punto 0 1 0 0 sea creció la equis y la
ye se hizo más pequeña vamos a hacer uno
más nada más así por pura diversión
entonces tenemos que meter aquí otro
cero vamos a evaluar la expresión en
1000 vamos a meter otro cero más y
finalmente aquí un último cero
y que nos queda pues si se sigue y se
sigue yendo a 0 vale entonces nos queda
algo todavía más pequeño y si en efecto
tenemos que cuando x se va infinito ya
se va a cero puedes probar otros valores
en tu calculadora por ti mismo vale
bueno ya que tenemos las actitudes
verticales y está siendo está horizontal
vamos a probar algunos valores para
entender el comportamiento por ejemplo
vamos a hacer una pequeña tabla le voy a
poner con este color verde limón
entonces vamos a poner aquí algunos
valores de xy de iu y vamos a entender
primero qué sucede aquí adentro en esa
línea que lo superficial déjame hacerla
con la realmente a con la herramienta de
línea recta entonces vamos a ver qué
sucede aquí adentro déjame poner de
valores
1 - 1 entonces cuánto nos quedaría y en
cada caso
aquí nos quedaría 0 entre 0 - 06 00 06
nos quedaría 0 entre -6 aquí voy a hacer
las cuentas 0 entre cualquier cosa que
no sea cero es cero entonces el punto
cero cero está en la gráfica voy a hacer
este de una vez a ver aquí nos quedaría
111 dividido entre 111 cuadrados 1 - 1 -
6 y éste se va con este nos queda menos
un sexto nos queda menos un sexto y
finalmente en x igual a menos uno aquí
voy a poner menos un sexto menos un
sexto y finalmente en x igual a menos
uno nos queda menos uno menos uno
dividido entre menos uno al cuadrado que
es uno menos menos uno menos seis esto
de aquí es menos uno entre 2 6 2 6 4
entonces nos queda igual a un cuarto
aquí nos queda un cuarto vamos a pasar
estos puntos a la gráfica entonces está
el 0 0 es este de acá está el 1 - un
sexto 1 como a menos un sexto más o
menos como por acá y el menos 1,4 menos
1 a lo mejor ese un 6º me quedo muy
arriba más bien sería como por ahí y
finalmente menos 1 como en cuarto menos
1,1 cuarto muy bien bueno están súper
pegaditos pero creo que aquí ya podemos
decir que sucede porque porque observa
necesitamos que al acercarnos a esta sin
total la función se pegue a ella y bueno
aquí ya tenemos que esto va creciendo
entonces entonces yo digo que la gráfica
se va a ver más o menos algo así vale
entonces aquí empieza a crecer y se
empieza a pegar a la cim total y acá de
un poco sueca para volver a hacerla ahí
va creciendo
ustedes no regresarse siempre ir hacia
la izquierda y crecer izquierda y crecer
bueno creo que es la idea verdad ahí
está y bueno digo esta fue como
intuición pero en realidad podemos
verificar que al acercarnos a este a
este punto a -2 de a de veras nos vamos
infinito cómo le hacemos pues podemos
tomar un punto cercano al menos 2 por la
derecha por ejemplo menos 1.9 9999 y
vamos a analizar qué sucede aquí menos
1.9 999 hace que lo de arriba sea
negativo que este de aquí sea negativo
verdad es menos menos algo menos otra
cosa y aquí menos algo más 2 es positivo
entonces tenemos menos entre menos que
es más y aquí hay otro más
entonces nos queda más entonces ésta va
a ser una expresión positiva pero x más
2 va a ser súper súper súper chiquito
súper súper cercano a 0 dividimos entre
algo súper cercano a 0 entonces toda la
expresión se hace muy grande se hace muy
grande y con signo positivo entonces por
eso nos vamos a infinito de manera
similar aquí y bueno del 0 pasamos a
algo negativo entonces lo que nos dice
en nuestra intuición es que tenemos que
irnos ahora a menos infinito entonces
aquí empieza a bajar y a bajar y nos
vamos acercando a la cinta pero nunca la
tocamos y en efecto también podemos
probar con valores cercanos a a3 por la
izquierda por ejemplo
2.999 92 puntos 999 hace que éste sea
positivo que éste sea positivo y que
esté de acá sea negativo entonces nos
queda algo negativo pero como esto es
muy chiquito todo queda muy grande nos
queda algo muy grande negativo y grande
negativo quiere decir que se va a menos
infinito vale que se va para allá bueno
entonces ahí están las explicaciones de
lo que sucede aquí adentro
vamos a probar algunos puntos más para
ver qué pasa por acá y para ver qué pasa
por acá entonces déjame tomar otro color
vamos a pasarnos a un color azul un poco
más fuerte entonces ahora vamos a hacer
otra pequeña tabla eso como una
continuación de esta pero la voy a poner
acá por para tener un poco más de
espacio entonces sí pongo x igual a 4
digamos por acá que sucede pues a ver
nos quedaría 4 aquí voy a hacer las
cuentas 4 dividido entre 4 al cuadrado
que es 16 - 4 - 4 - 6 16 menos 4 es 12 6
entonces nos queda 4 sextos 4 sextos y 4
sextos es lo mismo que dos tercios dos
tercios y finalmente voy a poner aquí el
menos tres para entender qué sucede por
acá entonces en menos tres menos tres
este punto en menos tres tenemos menos
tres dividido entre menos tres al
cuadrado que es 9 menos menos 3 que es
más 3 menos 6 nos queda menos tres menos
3 / 9 312 6 de 6
entonces nos queda menos un medio
tenemos queda menos un medio vale vamos
a copiar estos puntos aquí a nuestra
gráfica el 4,2 tercios uno dos tres
cuatro dos tercios más o menos va por
ahí y finalmente el menos tres coma
menos un medio menos 1 - 2 - 3 - un
medio más o menos son puntos aproximados
yo digo que con esto ya podemos entender
totalmente qué pasa porque ve aquí a la
derecha tenemos esta 5ta vertical a la
cual tenemos que acercarnos hacia ella
pero además tenemos que acercarnos a
esta 5ta horizontal
entonces al parecer la única forma de
completar esta función es venir desde
desde infinito en la cim total bajar sin
este está bien difícil de hacer déjame
hacerlo para el otro lado entonces más
bien empezando en este punto y
acercándonos al 3 tenemos que irnos a
infinito
sí creo que eso queda un poco mejor pero
todavía así es un poco chueco ahí está
ahí vamos nos acercamos más y más y
luego de este lado tenemos que
acercarnos a la 5ta horizontal aquí
igual a cero vale entonces ya tenemos lo
que pasa acá y finalmente veamos qué
sucede de este lado de este lado tenemos
que empezar cerca de la cim total
entonces empezar cerca de igual a cero y
tenemos que empezar a bajar hasta llegar
a este punto y luego tenemos que
pegarnos a estas in total de acá así que
tenemos que bajar tenemos que bajar
bajar chinesse si no quedó nada bien lo
voy a volver a hacer bueno se ve la idea
general verdad se ahora tenemos que
bajar y nada más acercarnos al asiento
está muy bien entonces bueno según
nuestro análisis así de graficar una
expresión racional la gráfica se ve más
o menos así finalmente para verificar
que todo haya salido muy bien déjame
dibujar esto en la calculadora para ver
que nos queda para verificar nuestra
respuesta entonces aquí está la cálculo
la enciendo no voy a graficar déjame
borrar esta expresión y tengo que poner
ahora la expresión x
x dividido entre x al cuadrado x al
cuadrado menos x menos x menos 6 menos 6
entonces suena el redoble de tambores y
si esto es exactamente lo que hicimos
bueno aquí se ve un poco chueco porque
en realidad no tiene tan buena
resolución la calculadora pero es la
misma idea verdad venimos a horizontales
bajamos cuando llegamos a esta sin tota
vertical luego venimos de infinito
bajamos otra vez nos vamos a infinito y
otra vez nos vamos para la sien total
horizontal de hecho podríamos ajustar un
poquito la vista para que se vea mejor a
lo mejor convenga poner aquí un -5 lo
voy a poner un -5 menos 5 y aquí voy a
poner un 5
y con un poco de suerte ahora se ve
mejor ahí está
si esto se ve mucho mejor entonces
venimos venimos baam tenemos una sin
tota
luego avanzamos avanzamos bajan segunda
sin tota y otra vez nos vamos a la 5ta
horizontal bueno espero que te hayan
parecido pues divertidos todos estos
ejemplos que hicimos y bueno espero que
te haya gustado el tema y que estos
vídeos te hayan sido de utilidad